Steam. You know, it wasn't so long ago that we learned how to harness the power of steam. Barely two centuries.
Joe, I remember you telling us that long ago in Alexandria, a man named Hero had already invented a steam machine. Wasn't that what you said?
Get ready for a big lesson on the Greeks.
Alexandria wasn't in Greece. It's in Egypt.
That's right, but Hero's invention had no real application, no practical use. You remember, children.
I invented a steam machine.
It's of no use.
No, it's true. It served no useful purpose.
You have to wait another 2,000 years before a Frenchman, Denis Papin, takes an interest once again in a steam machine.
It can generate a lot of power.
There is great power.
I don't know if it has power, but I do know it's hot.
To be careful, Monsieur Papin.
Too slow, your fancy machine, Monsieur Papin.
I'll make a bigger one.
Devalve, that's what it needs.
Starting to cook now, Monsieur Papin.
I just invented something else.
In no time at all, these vegetables are going to cook.
You concoct it now.
Already done! I call it a pressure cooker.
But you can't cook them in such a short time.
Bravo, Monsieur Papin! For once you have invented something useful!
What?
And so it was, children, that that was all that Denis Papin left us, the pressure cooker, but things would change.
In fact, it would be a veritable explosion in steam, you'll see.
Explosion, technologically speaking, naturally.
The first steam machine used industrially was invented by Newcombe in England.
Mr. Go on, we need more steam, go on.
Machine is uneconomical, I assure you.
It wastes coal.
Go on, Professor Watt.
Back in Scotland.
We abhor waste.
See how much steam's escaping into the air.
We can do nothing.
Ah, yes we can.
Can't see anything, it's too small.
There's also no need to waste paper.
Can't understand a thing.
You'll see.
Maestro, will you explain?
Explain how the wheel is turned just using steam?
Because steam, all it does is saw.
Yeah, it's all right, I'll try to explain it.
Now, slow down at this speed, we can't understand anything.
The steam comes into this sort of drawer that distributes it alternately to each side of the piston,
pushing one way and then the other, and it moves.
Does everybody understand?
Yeah, I understand.
That steam engine was to revolutionize the world.
It was only the start.
Oh, yes, soon others designed and built steam engines.
A Frenchman, Francois Cugnot, for instance.
You are convinced, Monsieur Cugnot, that your machine is able to transport this large cannon, that right?
You will see.
I would prefer you take it in through the door, sir, and not through the wall.
I'm trying, I'm trying!
No!
Fire the Englishman, Murdoch.
It is not allowed to put the mechanical devices on the road during the day, Murdoch.
Then I'll test it at night, Mr. Watt.
All right, but it's at your own risk.
My goodness.
It's not a toy, it's a scale model of the very first locomotive on rails.
There's no machine that'll have a good horse.
Just a few years later, in 1797...
Idea.
Just as well, hook an engine to the car and it would move on its own.
Been tried already, George. The machine is too heavy. It won't pull all the carts.
And the rails break.
Now what are you doing?
Nothing, Pop. It's just the piston. It's stuck.
Drop of oil should do it.
George?
Hold on. It'll work.
Son, you're good at mechanics.
I want to construct a real locomotive.
For that, I'll be needing a workshop.
Range that.
The first public train service running on rails would begin in 1803 in England and be pulled by horses.
Hey, that wasn't a real train.
Has to have a loco--
Yeah, you're right.
Very soon, real locomotives would appear.
See?
Run, Dad.
Wow, but it's too heavy to run for long.
Are you familiar with steam engines?
Yes, sir. I'm a trained mechanic.
Well, my machine is going to run so fast, nobody will beat it in a race, so I named it Catch Me If You Can.
Weighs about seven tons. Heavy for the rails.
Sure you, I know my job.
Take a ride on the locomotive. It's the transport of the future.
One shilling a ride, one shilling, a little shilling.
Hello, Dad. Can I have a ride? A good time.
Yes, all right, but sit on the outer side.
I'm still afraid that the rails will give way, and then you can jump.
Too heavy, huh?
What's needed is a much lighter machine, understand?
And so you want to build another locomotive, George?
Yes, sir, but one that's much lighter and so faster.
Just no word, my lord.
These locomotives are quite costly toys and clearly will never be any use.
Horses, now that's a good investment.
It's true, they cost a great deal.
Yes, my lord.
How much?
Many hundreds of pounds, perhaps a thousand.
Out of the question! Out of the question!
And if you do manufacture one, you sure it'll run?
Yes, sir. I guarantee it'll run.
Don't listen to him, my lord.
Canik, the man is not properly trained.
Well, I please trust in you, George.
Here's what you need for a workshop.
It's madness. I don't agree.
All that gold will be wasted.
Wood is light, and it's going to strengthen the boiler, son.
Ah, look. Look over there.
You see the two cylinders?
Well, the rods will transmit the movement of the pistons directly to the wheels.
But you, Robert, you have to go to school to be an engineer.
That way, you and I can work together.
For work.
The accounts are in a terrible state.
Salaries are too high, steel supplies too high,
pairs to the forge too high.
That's not all damages caused by explosion.
This is Bill's bill's bill.
As a result, she is.
I call her the locomotion.
With this engine, we're going to start the very first steam railway line.
He's crazy.
I second that.
Then let's build it.
Are you sure, George, that your locomotive will be ready in time?
Yes, quite sure. My son is in charge of the workshop. I have complete faith in him. The train will run.
Yeah, yeah, it runs. It runs up bills, your lordship.
We won't be needing them at all.
I certainly hope not.
This is going to be a great day in railroad history.
It's wonderful. I want to be in front of you.
Me too. Move over here.
You realize it's impossible.
Train won't run long.
Who's here?
Port of Liverpool by rail.
Question now is, who is going to construct this great project?
It's already decided. I have drawn the route.
The motive is ready. All we need is the money needed to construct it.
In just one minute, steam engines aren't yet proven the train is safer when it's drawn by horses.
As it happens, I am able to supply good quality horses.
Mr. James, we've examined your project.
We're not absolutely sure that the route you've chosen is necessarily the best,
nor that your locomotive is able to pull the train.
What do you mean? My locomotive is the best in the world, and I assure you, the route I've chosen is the shortest one.
To date, I believe the only steam-driven railway that's functioning is the one created by George Stevenson.
We have asked him to come.
Mr. Stevenson, and have you considered our project?
I have, and this is the route that I propose.
But the route he's made is much longer. It would be a waste of time.
It avoids steep grades and any sharp curbs along the route. They might derail the train.
Yes, of course. Now, what about the locomotive? What is your choice?
My opinion, it should be a new design, a boiler with pipes.
It's ridiculous.
The boiler design is cylindrical and it's a vertical.
No question, a horizontal boiler.
My locomotive's the best in the world.
And mine is simply better.
Gentlemen, gentlemen, do stay calm.
Each inventor thinks his is the best, yes, of course.
And so, there's only one way to settle this.
That is a race.
That's an excellent idea.
A locomotive race?
With a prize of five hundred pounds sterling?
A race! We can all place bets!
When will it be?
In October at Rainhill, near Liverpool.
And the minimum average speed has to be at least sixteen kilometres an hour.
To thank your honour for accepting an invitation.
This is going to begin.
Here are the judges, their decision is final.
It can't be questioned.
Going forward, the first candidate.
Sir Adrian, I wonder how he powers it.
That doesn't mean he qualifies a locomotive.
There's an hour.
Mr. Brandreth, we believe that your engine is not powered by steam.
What? Not steam? You come and see.
Don't tell me it's not steam. It ain't powered by steam.
In a way, it is steam, yes, but in any event, your average speed, sir, was only 8 kilometers an hour.
And the minimum for the race requires 16. Therefore, you are out.
Why didn't you tell me? I'd have brought two horses.
Next contestant.
Did it on stilts?
It looks quite like a grasshopper.
I don't think it will run for long, though.
For me, part of the glorious train saga, and before long, the next year, in fact,
the Manchester-Liverpool line would go into service.
In just a few decades, the steam railway would undergo a remarkable development,
spreading through all of Europe and America, where it would open up the Wild West.
Where was I again?
That's right. Stevenson, with his rocket, had gone over 30 kilometers an hour.
And today...
J.V., you realize 300 an hour?
That's right. And pretty soon, it could be 500.